so the verdict is in kyle rittenhouse
not guilty on all counts not guilty on
all counts that is very good news for
the country the president of the united
states joe biden who did finish his
colonoscopy uh he apparently cleaned him
out in some way because he came out and
he said that we should respect the
verdict because the jury system works
which is the best thing he has said in
his entire time as presidency so far as
i am concerned here was what it sounded
like when the jury announced its verdict
earlier
kyle written today
as the first count of the information
joseph rosenbaum we need the jury to
find the defendant kyle h rittenhouse
not guilty
as to the second count of the
information richard mcginnis we the jury
find the defendant kyle h ridden house
not guilty
as to the third count of the information
unknown mail we the jury find the
defendant kyle h rittenhouse not guilty
as to the fourth count of the
information anthony huber we the jury
find the defendant kyle h rittenhouse
not guilty
as to the fifth count of the information
gage rose croix we the jury find the
defendant kyle a
kyle h rittenhouse not guilty
members of the jury are these your
unanimous verdicts
is there anyone who does not agree with
the verdicts as read
okay if you can't see the video
rittenhouse essentially collapses in
tears
now remember we were told by the entire
blue check marked media that when he
cried on the stand while recounting what
happened to him that night it was
because white tears white tears was all
fake just like it was fake for brett
kavanaugh i want you to remember this
because the media lied to you and they
lied to you routinely never forget that
these people created this situation in
the first place remember this all began
with a lie it began with the lie that
jacob blake was an alleged rapist
the police were calm on him because he
went to his ex-girlfriend's home she
called the cops the police arrived he
resisted arrest he had a knife and
turned his back on the cops while
holding a knife and was shot for his
trouble
the media treated that as a vicious
white supremacist murdered by the cops
that led to riots and kenosha those
riots in kenosha were defended by the
media as mostly peaceful kyle
writtenhouse then went to kenosha in
order to protect private property and
provide medical aid at which point he
was attacked by three people
all of whom had significant criminal
records
one of whom was an actual convicted
child molester he shot two of them all
three were white
and then the media declared that kyle
rittenhouse was a white supremacist mass
shooter the media created the situation
they fomented the situation they lit the
fire and then they watched it burn and
then they found the flames because this
is what they are they are garbage
beginning to end they lied to you they
lied about the situation they continue
to lie today
i'll go all the way back to the
beginning this is right after the
written house shootings here's a little
compendium of our friends in the media
completely botching the facts and lying
to americans over and over and over
again
ridden house is basically what you would
have had in a school shooter he's a 17
year old kid he shouldn't have had a gun
he crossed state lines to supposedly
protect property no he was going out to
shoot people kyle rittenhouse the 17
year old vigilante kyle rittenhouse the
vigilante kyle rittenhouse the armed
teenage vigilante a 17 year old
vigilante
arguably a domestic terrorist picked up
a rifle drove to a different state to
shoot people kyle rittenhouse
a guy who's deeply racist went with
weapons to a black lives matter protest
looking to get in trouble he did he
murdered a couple of people rittenhouse
uh the 17 year old kid just running
around
shooting and killing protesters you see
the 17 year old who was radicalized by
trumpism took his ar-15 to kenosha and
became a killer a white trump-supporting
maga loving uh blue lives matter social
media uh partisan 17 years old picks up
a gun drives from one state to another
with the intent to shoot people
these people are garbage they were lying
to you at the time and here's the thing
now that we know
they continue to lie they continue to
lie
okay and the biden
campaign lied about kyle rittenhouse
this was not just the media there's a
democrat media complex dedicated to the
lie that what happened in kenosha was a
righteous explosion of anger at white
supremacy in the united states and
therefore the kyle written house was an
evil emissary of the trump campaign and
white supremacy more generally
this was a this was a lie that was
promulgated by joe biden's campaign
it was joe biden and kamala harris who
were calling up
jacob blake
it was
kamala harris the current vice president
of the united states who told alleged
rapist jacob blake that she was proud of
him
that she was proud of him
it was the president of the united
states who called up
jacob blake
and talked with him
and said he talked about how nothing was
going to defeat him they fomented this
here was an ad from the joe biden
campaign september 2020
are you willing tonight to condemn white
supremacists and militia groups and to
say that they need to stand down and not
add to the violence in a number of these
cities as we saw in kenosha and as we've
seen in portland are you prepared to
specifically do it
there's the image of kyle rittenhouse in
the middle of that joe biden campaign ad
they created this they own it
and now here's the thing they got caught
in the lie just like with covington
catholic just like with brett kavanaugh
just like with the russia hoax just like
with all of it they got caught in the
lie because they are
liars because they are liars beginning
to end the narrative is the only thing
that matters and they were willing to
make the blood sacrifice of kyle
rittenhouse in order to promote that
narrative
and here's the thing they are still
willing to make the blood sacrifice in
order to promote the narrative because
now the facts are out it was justifiable
at the beginning to say you know what
let's wait let's see
and then it became pretty quickly not
justifiable because all the tape emerged
and then the prosecution happened and
maybe the prosecution had something
maybe they had a piece of evidence that
we didn't know about it maybe they knew
something that you didn't but it turned
out they knew nothing it turned out they
had no evidence they had nothing nada in
fact all of their witnesses were defense
witnesses
and still the media couldn't stop lying
still the political actors in the
democratic party could not stop lying
kyle rittenhouse had to be the face of
evil white supremacy kyle rittenhouse
had to be the face of trumpism and even
after his acquittal today the media
continued to promulgate the lie they are
rewriting history in real time you don't
let them do it i won't let them do it
none of us should let them do it they
are liars and allowing them to rewrite
history in real time rewrite fact
patterns in real time it means the end
of the country the end of the truth
we're gonna fight that so as i say the
democratic media complex they created
this and they are liars and they will
maintain the lie just because kyle
writtenhouse is acquitted today as he
should have been legally and morally
does not mean that these bastards won't
continue to lie to you and lie about you
and lie about the country and lie about
the state of play
now earlier i said that joe biden come
out and he had said that he didn't watch
the trial and so he really had no
opinion and the jury had done its job
that's what joe biden said now he's
released a statement it's amazing the
man can't do anything right for more
than 22 seconds before ron klein steers
him wrong again he just released a
statement did our
not all their president quote well the
verdict in kenosha will leave many
americans feeling angry and concerned
myself included we must acknowledge that
the jury has spoken
why are you angry and concerned was it
because you slandered kyle rittenhouse's
white supremacist in your campaign ad
are you angry and concerned because you
might sue your ass for defamation as you
probably should
why are you angry and concerned sir what
do you know about this trial that we
don't
they are liars and they will rewrite
history to make the lie stick
this is why they keep trotting out
michael brown as though he was in
innocence or jacob blake as though he
was an innocent
because all that matters is the
narrative they will continue to lie and
lie and lie do not pay attention to them
get better news sources and tell all
your friends to do the same
here let me just give you this here is
yahoo news's description this is post
acquittal okay post acquittal here is
their description of what happened to
written house quote
rittenhouse was 17 when he carried an ar
style semi-automatic rifle on the
streets of kenosha during a turbulent
protest against racial injustice in the
summer of 2020 and opened fire on
demonstrators killing joseph rosenbaum
and anthony huber and seriously wounding
gage gross croods
okay that is the least accurate
description of what happened i have ever
seen
according to yahoo news after the trial
after the video after drone footage
after witness testimony after physical
evidence
after that their description of this was
not kyle rittenhouse went to kenosha in
the middle of riots to defend private
property he was accosted by a convicted
child molester and chased he turned
around and shot that man when he lunged
for the gun then he was chased by a mob
who was trying to kill him and he shot
two other people killing one that would
be an accurate depiction of what
happened according to yahoo news he just
arrived during a turbulent protest and
then opened fire on demonstrators just
randomly spraying them with bullets
apparently
these liars they are liars
they lie to you
and if this were you they would lie
about you
because they don't care how many eggs
they have to break in order to make the
omelet they do not care if you are if
you are an obstacle to their utopian
vision of what america should be like
they will break you they will destroy
you
they would have gladly sent a 17 year
old kid to prison for the rest of his
life for an act of self-defense and they
are weeping today because
kyle rittenhouse isn't going to spend
the rest of his life behind bars for a
crime he never committed and didn't
commit on video
here was cnn today to decrying the legal
process oh well you know the problem
with the legal process says cnn is that
you know really the law is just
favorable to the defendant
the law in wisconsin is very favorable
to a defendant claiming self-defense the
prosecution has to affirmatively
disprove self-defense beyond a
reasonable doubt if the jury went back
there and had some reasonable doubt then
they were to return a not guilty verdict
and that it appears is what they've done
well you know the the law of self by the
way can i explain something the law of
self-defense is a key element of every
legal regime ever in human history if
there's a legal regime it includes the
law of self-defense that is the only law
that mattered here this is not because
the law was favorable to the defense
it's because the defendant didn't commit
a crime they all know this but they're
going to lie they're going to pretend
that he got off on a technicality he did
not get off on a technicality kyle
written house he got off because he
never should have been indicted in the
first place and only because the
prosecutor is a despicable lying hack
was this ever brought
by the way this speaks to a broader fact
which is that republicans conservatives
freedom-minded people need to start
electing da's who aren't
outgrowths of a progressive legal
thinking system that believes that you
should indict people for no reason so
long as they fit the check marks that
you need for your narrative
it wasn't just that guy on cnn got bob
bianchi former head prosecutor from new
jersey morris county new jersey on cnn
saying you know innocence well yeah it's
a mistaken belief
it's not about narratives it's
unfortunate that narratives is the tale
of the wagon the dog here it's the facts
that came out there in the course of the
case that showed that those narratives
were in large part completely inaccurate
and so this jury did its job by looking
at the facts taking its time
deliberating over the evidence and even
though it may have been a mistaken
belief they believe kyle rittenhouse
under those circumstances felt not only
death but great bodily harm a lot of
people are missing that
mistaken belief where's the mistaken
belief coming from he's doing well until
he gets to mistaken belief okay this
isn't the worst of the worst okay
there's not even close to the worst of
the worst you got msnbc
all of their guests doing the same thing
eugene robinson says this is a
vindication of vigilantism weird because
what it seems like more is a vindication
of the fact that if a child molester
tries to grab your gun you can shoot him
or the vindication of the fact that if a
man approaches you with a pistol to
shoot you you're allowed to shoot him in
the bicep or the fact that if somebody
tries to smack you in the face with a
skateboard repeatedly you can shoot him
that doesn't sound super a lot like
vigilantism
you know it's so there are unique things
about this case but i what concerns me
though is that the result will be seen
as a vindication of vigilantism
of what kyle rittenhouse was doing the
larger context of what he was doing uh
you know during these demonstrations
over the shooting of of jacob blake
you got ben rhodes doing the same
routine the former hack writer turned
foreign policy advisor he says quote a
very dark message sent to all the other
heavily armed would-be vigilantes out
there oh it's about vigilantism now
well you know what for most of them it's
about race they're still trying to turn
this into a race case every person kyle
written how shot was white cal
rittenhouse is white there are no black
people involved in this case period none
it does not matter you know what's
trending on twitter today black lives
matter black lives matter is trending on
twitter this case does not include a
single black human
not one it does not matter it has to fit
the narrative
which is why you have for example
celeste ing who is the writer of little
fires everywhere tweeting out so
basically it's cool to just have an
ar-15 and go out and hunt black people
as long as you're white
the people he shot weren't even black
the what are you talking about doesn't
matter
stephen king
quote so the white guy goes free is that
the message
no the message is that the white guy can
defend himself just like anybody else
hey you have nicole hannah jones
remember nicole hannah jones is seen as
a real intellectual by the left
i don't know what to make of that
i honestly don't know whether that means
that the left is just so unbelievably
stupid like with the brain power of an
earthworm
that that to them she looks brilliant or
they're just patronizing her by
pretending that she's smart because
nicole hannah jones has never said a
true thing as far as i'm aware
it was just last week when she claimed
that we dropped the a-bomb on hiroshima
and nagasaki because of the sunk cost
fallacy because we wanted to prove that
we'd spent our money wisely
on the manhattan project i mean she's
she's a complete fool from beginning to
end so here's what this complete fool
had to tweet quote
in this country you can even kill white
people and get away with it if those
white people are fighting for black
lives this is the legacy of 1619.
so just to get this straight a white man
shooting a white child molester and a
white criminal and a white person trying
to kill him is the legacy of 1619
weird
weird take by nicole hannah jones by the
way she then followed up that tweet by
suggesting that he crossed state lines
with a gun which didn't even do
because she doesn't know what the hell
she's talking about because she doesn't
care what she's talking about because
the facts do not matter they don't
matter
here's joy reid the bloviating bag of
stupid over on msnbc quote we knew but
it's sometimes helpful to remind
ourselves how america was designed to
work it continues to work as design we
have learned again what is considered
legal for some people to do in america
it's helpful to know where you stand in
your country be safe out there
what what's it's
self-defense is legal for everyone joy
for everyone but she says only some
people only some people will be
acquitted under these circumstances
weird because at the beginning of
october
the city of chicago literally refused to
prosecute a case
in which
uh two members of gangs were shooting at
each other one person died and two
suspects were wounded and the city of
chicago was like we're not even going to
prosecute them
everyone involved was a person of color
okay like i don't know the hell she's
talking about what she thinks she's
talking about but this passes for wisdom
in left-wing circles
she also put out a blog post not not the
old blog post where she uh ripped on gay
people a new blog post it says kyle
rittenhouse trial was designed to
protect white conservatives who kill
nailed it meanwhile leticia james who
wants to run for governor of new york
after kneecapping andrew cuomo she
tweeted out this is a dark day for our
justice system as a lawyer i respect
jury verdicts but this is yet another
reminder that our system needs to be
uprooted and reformed
so you don't respect jury verdicts
you just want to destroy the system
these folks are they're rewriting
history and i promise you three years
from now
the left will still be saying that kyle
rittenhouse is a white supremacist
murderer they will still be citing the
name of joseph rosenbaum as some sort of
martyr to the cause of black lives
even though he's the only person in the
entire situation who did anything that
had to do with race by the way what do
you have to do with race that he shouted
the n word
but he was the guy defending black lives
corey bush
the liar who suggested that when she was
marching in ferguson missouri white
people were camped out on a hill nearby
shooting at her which is a complete lie
fabrication made up top to bottom she
tweeted out the judge the jury the
defendant it's white supremacy in action
this system isn't built to hold white
supremacists accountable
that's why black and brown folks are
brutalized and put in cages while white
supremacist murderers walk free i'm hurt
i'm angry i'm heartbroken
amazing
the narrative demands that this be about
the subjugation of black people
there are no black people involved so
they'll just ignore that and just go
right for it anyway
it's incredible by the way i hope kyle
rittenhouse sues these sues these
jackasses into the ground i hope that he
covington catholics these people into
bankruptcy i hope that kyle rittenhouse
has a house made of money when all this
is over
i hope that kyle rittenhouse
is sitting atop a pile of cash because
of these people
just because they are liars and they
deserve it
bill de blasio the commie groundhog
murderer from new york he tweeted out
anthony huber and joseph rosenbaum are
victims they should be alive today
they're victims you see
anthony huber
who was convicted of assaulting his
brother and mother and joseph rosenbaum
convicted child molester both of whom
attempted to murder a 17 year old
they're victims according to mayor bill
de blasio that's not a surprise he is
kind of friendly with some terrorist
groups he says they should be alive
today the only reason they're not is
because a violent dangerous man chose to
take a gun across state lines and start
shooting people to call this a
miscarriage of justice is an
understatement it's a lie it's all
entirely a lie and they know it's a lie
and they don't care they don't this is
the part that's so mind-boggling just if
you're a moral human being you should
care at least a little about the truth
of particular fact patterns they don't
care at all
it's not like we don't have video of
this stuff we have video of kyle
rittenhouse that night before any of the
shootings take place explaining why he
was there this is clip 22. here's kyle
rittenhouse that night explaining why he
was there does this sound like a young
man who's looking to murder people
does this sound like a young man who who
is looking to come to kenosha and just
start strafing people with bullets
so people are getting injured
and our job is to protect this business
and part of my job is to also help
people if there's somebody hurt i'm
running into harm's way that's why i
have my rifle because i need to protect
myself obviously i also have my med kit
we're protecting from the citizens and i
just got pepper sprayed by a person in
the crowd
so you had non-lethal you
so you guys are full and ready to defend
the property
yes we are okay now if i can ask can you
guys step back medical ems right here
okay and then at the end of the video
he's called off to do some medical help
for one of the people who's writing
sounds like a guy who's just out there
to murder people
adriano espayat who is a representative
from new york congressman he said kyle
rittenhouse is living proof that white
tears can still forestall justice a
murderer is once again walking free
today our system is terribly broken why
because kyle rittenhouse cried he had
the temerity to cry in court white tears
they're just reading from the hymnal of
robin d'angelo white tears are bad
because white tears illicit emotional
responses in white juries and this is
just another example of black people
being subjugated you know the pretzels
they have to twist themselves in to
stick their heads this far up their own
asses
honest to god joe biden and other
democrats who think like he does about
these particular issues i have to wonder
why they even had to perform a
colonoscopy couldn't joe biden just see
in there
apparently all the democrats can
gavin newsom
the androgynous human kendall
governor of california he tweeted
america today you can break the law
carry around weapons built for a
military shoot and kill people and get
away with it
that's the message we've just sent to
armed vigilantes across the nation
is it no
is that the message that we sent because
the message that you guys kept sending
is that riots were good property
destruction was good
hell attempting to murder a 17 year old
was good all of that was good that made
you a hero it made you a person worthy
of emulation and defense
they are rewriting reality in real time
and if you're not mad about it you got
to get mad about it it's important to be
mad about it it's important because you
need to tell everyone you know that
these people are liars and they cannot
be trusted because if they lie about
this they lie about everything and they
do
and they do so the liars are lying and
they will continue lying until you
believe the lie that is the message that
we are getting from our media today and
from the democrat media complex
generally
the aclu which used to be in favor of
civil liberties i'm old enough to
remember when they were in favor of
civil liberties i mean it was right in
their name a-c-l-u the c and the l stood
for civil liberties now they're tweeting
out just lies about kyle rittenhouse
quote despite kyle rittenhouse's
conscious decision to travel across
state lines and injure one person and
take the lives of two people protesting
the shooting of jacob placed by jacob
blake by police
he was not held responsible for his
actions unfortunately this is not
surprising this is not surprising it is
far too easy to overlook the impact that
violence and defense of white supremacy
has on the black and brown communities
there's no evidence that he was a white
supremacist
also by the way you will notice that you
know one of the things you're allowed to
do in the united states is drive across
straight to state lines
despite his conscious decision to travel
across state lines says the aclu
you know it's a thing that you're
allowed to do in the united states drive
across state lines
and also his conscious decision to
defend himself which was the entire
basis of his defense the aclu is a joke
but they're all jokes the daily show
hilarious the daily show so funny the
daily show they tweeted out just in
judge schrader senses kyle rittenhouse
to come give him a big hug because
that's what this is all about isn't it
it's all about all of the white people
getting together and giving each other
hugs that's what it's all about
that's isn't that charming isn't that
charming meanwhile i got nina turner
who is a running who's running for the
house in ohio's 11th district tweeting
quote
america doesn't have a justice system we
have an injustice system a clever you
see what you did right there you should
put an in in front of the justice he
said america doesn't have a justice
system we have an injustice system one
that sees nothing wrong with cops
shooting jacob blake in the back and
nothing wrong with killing people
protesting that shooting
uh jacob lake was correctly shot
and no i don't have any problem with
people being shot in self-defense they
were not shot protesting the shooting
again they are just changing the fact
pattern they're just changing the fact
pattern
and lying about it and i'm never going
to get over this i'm never going to get
over the fact that they just make they
just make bleep up that's what they do
it's disgusting it really is
all the entire left wing has decided to
just make things up it's incredible
here's colin kaepernick quote we just
witnessed a system built on white
supremacy validate the terroristic act
of a white supremacist no evidence
whatsoever presented at trial before or
after that kyle written houses a white
supremacist
this only further validates the need to
abolish our current system white
supremacy cannot be reformed
says the former backup quarterback who
kneels for the national anthem and earns
millions of dollars while getting
specials on netflix by the way the only
evidence i've ever seen in my life that
capitalism ought to be abolished is the
fact that colin kaepernick makes money
that is the only reason i've ever seen
that makes any sense to me is why
capitalism needs to be overthrown
because if
complete
idiots
in the technical sense like colin
kaepernick can make enormous quantities
of money
lying about the united states and
whining about the united states while
pulling down those kind of checks maybe
that is a problem with capitalism that
is the only marxist case i've ever seen
made is colin kaepernick
meanwhile representative jerry nadler he
tweeted out that the verdict was
heartbreaking quote this heartbreaking
verdict is a miscarriage of justice and
sets a dangerous precedent which
justifies federal review by the doj
so now he wants garland to come in and
review the case
justice cannot tolerate armed person
crossing state lines looking for trouble
while protest while people engage in
first amendment protected protest
again it's just every element of that is
a lie
he was not armed when he crossed the
state line
second he was not looking for trouble
third the people who he shot were not
engaged in first amendment protest you
know what's not first amendment protest
drawing a gun on a guy while approaching
him like gage gross groots or bashing
somebody in the head like anthony huber
was doing with a skateboard
or chasing somebody down and trying to
grab their gun
like jason like joseph rosenbaum
okay the fact that they lie like this
means you should always doubt their
narratives you should always doubt it
because there's not one iota of evidence
to back anything that they are saying
the trial if they had watched it for
five seconds and cared about the truth
would have debunked every argument they
were making every single one
the prosecution's own witnesses were
debunking these arguments gage gross
croods for example admitted he pulled a
gun on written house before written
house shot him but apparently he's a
victim engaging in first amendment
protected activities according to these
jackasses
his clip 23 gauge gross groups admitting
in open court that he was justifiably
shot
it wasn't until you pointed your gun at
him
advanced on him with your gun now your
hands down pointed at him
that he fired right
correct
unreal but it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter because they must have their
talking points so understand this
when it comes to the media when it comes
to the democrats you don't matter
individuals don't matter the only thing
that matters is the stories they can
derive from a bunch of false fact
patterns they make up and if the fact
patterns don't fit they will just
rewrite the fact patterns they will just
say things that aren't true they're
doing it right now in real time they're
trending george floyd on twitter as
though this has something to do with
george floyd they're turning black lives
matter on twitter as though this has
something to do with black lives matter
they're suggesting
openly that kyle rittenhouse is a white
supremacist some of them are going so
far the uk independent is suggesting
that he shot black people
none of that's true it doesn't matter
the narrative will morph the facts will
morph to meet the narrative
because when you have a vision of utopia
the way the left does lives don't matter
they don't they would have been
perfectly happy today if kyle
rittenhouse had been sentenced to life
in prison for defending himself
from criminals attempting to murder him
they would have been happy today they
would have been celebrating in the
streets
what's one blood sacrifice or another
between friends seeking utopia
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed